Im März 2019 zeigte "DOK"
eine Reportage der RTS-Kollegen
über den Babyhandel in Sri Lanka
in den Jahren zwischen 1980 und 2000.
Gestohlene Kinder ...
... hintergangene Mütter ...
... gefälschte Dokumente.
Zu der Zeit boomt der Markt
mit internationalen Adoptionen.
Kinderlose Paare aus Europa
und der Schweiz
unterstützen diesen Babyhandel -
ohne es zu wissen.
In der Schweiz
stecken die zuständigen Behörden
den Kopf in den Sand.
Heute sind die adoptierten Babys
erwachsen
und suchen
nach ihren leiblichen Eltern.
Ein schwieriges Unterfangen, da
die meisten Dokumente gefälscht sind.
Auch in anderen Ländern
wurde gleich gehandelt.
Im Libanon z.B., wo wir auf einen
weiteren Skandal gestossen sind.
* Wehmütige, östliche Klänge *
Wir treffen Sarah Ineichen
in Morges wieder.
Sarah hat in der RTS-Reportage
ihre Geschichte erzählt.
Wie sie im Alter von wenigen Wochen
von ihrer leiblichen Mutter getrennt
und als Adoptivkind
in die Schweiz verkauft wurde.
Heute trifft Sarah
Catherine Bezencon.
Sie ist ebenfalls
Opfer des Babyhandels.
(Beide) Salut!
1984 adoptiert Catherine Bezencon
voller Zuversicht
zwei Kinder aus Sri Lanka.
Sie ging davon aus,
dass sie alles richtig gemacht hatte
mit einem legalen Adoptionsprozess
in der Schweiz.
Erst durch die Reportage
erfährt sie von den Machenschaften
bei den Adoptionen in Sri Lanka.
Das war eine schallende Ohrfeige.
Ich fühlte mich betrogen,
ich weinte, ich war am Ende.
Ich kam mir vor,
als hätte ich etwas gestohlen,
als hätte ich
etwas Schlechtes getan,
dabei wollten wir etwas Gutes tun.
Catherine Bezencon will Sarah
erzählen, was damals vor sich ging.
Man hat uns
die Kinder in die Arme gelegt.
Das war alles bei ihr?
- Ja, bei ihr.
Bei "ihr" -
d.h. bei Miss Dawn da Silva.
Sie ist eine der Vermittlerinnen,
die den Babyhandel organisiert hat.
Für sie
arbeitete eine Anwaltskanzlei,
die die Adoptionen mit
den falschen Müttern legalisierte.
Ein sehr lukratives Geschäft.
Il y a encore le sapin de Noel.
Im Gang draussen
lebten noch andere Kinder,
die adoptiert werden sollten,
unter schlimmen Bedingungen.
Diese beiden Fotos wurden gemacht,
bevor wir ankamen.
Das hier ist meine Tochter
und das mein Sohn,
ganz klein und allein.
Er liegt in seinen Exkrementen,
und überall sind Fliegen.
Es war kaum auszuhalten.
Was denkst du, wenn du
heute diese Bilder anschaust,
nachdem du
die Reportage gesehen hast?
Das ist eine Industrie,
es ist unmöglich.
Aber wir wussten damals
nicht viel über das Ausland,
Sri Lanka kannten wir gar nicht.
Wir wussten nicht,
ob es überall so ist, diese Armut.
Wir kamen nicht auf die Idee, dass
es nicht mit rechten Dingen zugeht.
Catherine ist verbittert.
Damals hat keine Schweizer Behörde
sie
auf irgendetwas aufmerksam gemacht.
Ich wurde sehr wütend,
auch auf die Behörden,
weil ich erfuhr, dass sie
zumindest teilweise davon wussten.
Wir mussten uns
als glaubwürdig ausweisen,
wurden genauestens
unter die Lupe genommen,
und sie wussten schon, dass mit
den Adoptionen etwas nicht stimmte.
Aber niemand sagte uns etwas.
Oui.
- Je vois bien.
Sarah Jaques
wurde 1986 in Sri Lanka adoptiert.
Sie trifft sich mit ihrem Anwalt.
Er ist auch ihr Cousin und hilft ihr,
ihre leibliche Mutter
und ihre Wurzeln zu finden.
Du musst diese Unterscheidung
kennen, das genaue Prozedere,
und musst klar sagen:
"Ich will das und das."
Wenn du das nicht tust,
erhältst du die nötigen Dokumente
wohl nicht sofort.
Sarah Jaques ist ebenfalls durch
Dawn da Silva vermittelt worden.
In der Schweiz kommt sie
zu Adoptiveltern im Kanton Neuenburg.
Am Anfang läuft alles gut.
Doch mit der Pubertät
kommen die Fragen zu ihrer Identität.
Ihr wird schnell bewusst,
dass es nicht einfach ist,
danach zu suchen,
wenn man
praktisch keine Anhaltspunkte hat.
Es braucht viel Mut,
als Adoptierte hinzustehen
und seinen Adoptiveltern
und dem ganzen Umfeld zu sagen:
"Ich will wissen, wo ich herkomme."
Ich dachte, dass ich
in dieser Situation allein bin,
dass ich allein
gegen die Behörden kämpfen muss.
Aber dann begriff ich,
dass wir viele sind.
Ich hoffe ganz fest, dass das hilft.
On voit pas bien, mais la date,
en fait, est avant ma naissance.
Zuerst wendet sie sich
an die Gemeinde.
Ohne Erfolg.
Dann an den Kanton.
Es dauert fünf Jahre,
bis sie teilweise Antworten bekommt.
Sie erhält ihr Adoptionsdossier,
allerdings ist es nicht vollständig.
Es fehlen wichtige Teile.
Einiges scheint da nicht zu stimmen.
Ein Dokument,
das das Einverständnis
zur Adoption bestätigt,
ist datiert,
bevor Sarah überhaupt zur Welt kam.
Wie kann ein Gericht
eine Adoption gutheissen,
ohne diese Unklarheit
zur Sprache zu bringen?
Wenn man nachfragt, gibt es
niemanden bei der Verwaltung,
der sagt: "Das ist das Dossier, hier
haben Sie alles, was dazugehört."
In diesem Fall hat die Behörde
uns zwar das Dossier gegeben,
aber ohne uns zu sagen,
dass es irgendwo in einem Archiv
noch ein anderes gibt.
Falsche Papiere, inkorrekte Daten,
Namen, die ins Leere führen.
Das alles lässt wenig Hoffnung,
die biologische Familie zu finden.
Mit diesen Dokumenten
weiss ich nicht, ob ich etwas finde.
Auch wenn ich
die Hoffnung nicht aufgebe.
Mein Kampf besteht auch darin,
die Wahrheit aufzudecken,
v.a. was die Dokumente betrifft,
damit ich
auf meiner Suche weiterkomme.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich
meine Mutter jemals finden werde,
weil alles gefälscht ist,
vieles fehlt.
Aber ich möchte wenigstens
die Wahrheit kennen.
Doch auf der für Adoptionen
zuständigen Behörde findet man,
es laufe alles gut.
Wenn uns jemand
um sein Dossier bittet,
dann finden wir es
meist in relativ kurzer Zeit,
etwa innerhalb eines Monats.
Im nächsten Monat findet dann in
der Regel das erste Treffen statt.
In den Dossiers findet man meist
die wesentlichen Hinweise
in Bezug auf die Adoption, die aus
rechtlicher Sicht notwendig sind.
Wie z.B.
die Geburtsurkunden der Kinder?
Waren die Dossiers bei den Kindern
aus Sri Lanka diesbezüglich komplett?
Die Geburtsurkunden sind da.
Aber sind die Geburtsurkunden echt?
Hören Sie,
es handelt sich um Geburtsurkunden,
unterzeichnet und abgestempelt
von den sri-lankischen Behörden -
vergleichbar mit Thailand
oder den Philippinen heute.
Wir haben nicht die Kapazität,
diese Dokumente zu verifizieren,
sie zurückzuschicken, weil es früher
einmal einen Betrug gegeben hat.
Im Fall von Sri Lanka ist es weniger
die Richtigkeit der Geburtsurkunde
als die Richtigkeit der Abstammung,
die angefragt wird.
Wenn also in einem Dossier
auf der Geburtsurkunde
der Name der Mutter XY ist
und auf der Adoptionsurkunde steht
bei der Mutter ein anderer Name,
dann sollte man sich doch schon
ein paar Fragen stellen, oder nicht?
Absolut,
diese Fragen muss man stellen.
Das ist aber nicht geschehen.
Ich kann nichts dazu sagen.
Ich war nicht dabei.
Ich kann nicht bestätigen,
dass man sich keine Fragen stellte.
Stehen die Kantone - Neuenburg,
um bei diesem Beispiel zu bleiben -
nicht in der Verantwortung
in dieser Sache?
Der Kanton hat eine Verantwortung,
die man jedoch im Zusammenhang
mit den Ereignissen sehen muss.
Und ausserdem handelt es sich
bei der Frage nach der Verantwortung
um eine rechtliche Frage,
also müsste man sie
der Rechtsabteilung stellen
oder besser noch: dem Staatsrat.
Genau das haben wir getan.
Wir verlangten ein Interview mit
SP-Staatsrätin Monika Maire-Hefti,
Chefin des Erziehungs-
und Bildungsdepartements
und somit zuständig
für diese Angelegenheit.
Sie hat abgelehnt.
Dann fragten wir den gesamten
Staatsrat von Neuenburg an.
Wieder eine Absage.
Die Regierung schreibt uns:
"Die Entscheidungskompetenz
für eine Adoption
fällt in die Zuständigkeit
der Justizbehörde
und jene der Ausweispapiere
in die des Bundes."
Eine erstaunliche Antwort.
Der Bundesrat
hielt nämlich in einer Mitteilung
vom 14. Februar 2018 fest:
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Wir sind im Wallis,
bei Gaelle Tornay.
Gaelle hat 1980
eine glückliche Adoption erlebt.
Sie kam durch die Vermittlung
der Schweizerin Alice Honegger
in die Schweiz.
In ihrem Fall - und das ist selten -
ist die Geburtsurkunde korrekt.
Und so macht sie sich auf die Suche
nach ihrer leiblichen Mutter.
Meine Eltern sagten mir von Anfang
an, dass ich adoptiert bin.
Meine Mutter
konnte mich nicht behalten,
deshalb
übergab sie mich Adoptiveltern,
die sich sehnlichst
ein Kind wünschten.
Meine Adoptivmutter
schilderte das immer sehr positiv.
Ein idyllisches Bild,
das brutal zusammenbricht,
als Gaelle 2017
erstmals in einem TV-Bericht
vom Kinderhandel in Sri Lanka
erfährt.
... que des enfants ont ete voles
ou achetes au Sri Lanka,
puis adoptes
par des couples suisses.
Ich hatte plötzlich den Eindruck,
dass mein ganzes Leben falsch ist.
Das klingt vielleicht idiotisch,
weil ich doch eine solide Basis habe
mit einer tollen Familie.
Das geht an die Nieren
und ich hatte das Gefühl,
gar nicht mehr zu existieren.
Gaelle nimmt Kontakt auf
zur Schweizer Botschaft in Colombo.
Sie will
ihre leibliche Mutter finden.
Die Botschaft
macht die Mutter ausfindig,
Gaelle trifft sie in Colombo,
sie fallen sich in die Arme.
Aber Gaelle ist unsicher.
Sie verlangt einen DNS-Test.
Die Antwort ist brutal:
Es ist nicht ihre Mutter.
Ich fühlte mich sehr schuldig.
- Schuldig wofür?
Dass ich dieser Mutter
Hoffnungen gemacht habe.
Sie dachte doch auch,
sie hätte ihre Tochter gefunden,
Ich hatte von Anfang an
meine Zweifel,
als ich die Dokumente aus Sri Lanka
studierte.
Jemand von der Botschaft
sagte mir noch:
"Ach, Dokumente in Sri Lanka,
das ist nicht dasselbe
wie in der Schweiz,
es ist normal,
wenn einiges nicht übereinstimmt."
"Aber es ist schon Ihre Mutter."
Wir zeigen Gaelle ein Dokument
des Bundesamts für Ausländerfragen
von 1982.
Es handelt sich um
das Eintrittsformular in die Schweiz
für Adoptivkinder.
"Zum Zeitpunkt der Antragstellung
ist die Identität des Kindes
oft nicht bekannt oder ungenau."
"Aus diesem Grund verwenden wir
den Namen, der uns angegeben wurde,
selbst wenn er nicht ganz exakt ist
oder nicht
mit der Realität übereinstimmt."
"Diese Tatsache ist unwichtig,
denn die echte Identität des Kindes
wird bei seiner Ankunft
mithilfe eines gültigen Passes
gebildet werden."
Das schockiert mich.
Es steht da, schwarz auf weiss.
Was schockiert Sie am meisten?
Dass hier steht,
diese Tatsache sei unwichtig.
Ein Name definiert,
welche Person man werden wird.
Es ist die Essenz eines Menschen.
Wir sind doch Menschen
und keine kleinen Welpen.
Wir sind Menschen,
und denen gibt man einen Namen.
Ich finde das sehr patriarchalisch.
Das bedeutet:
"Ach, diese armen, kleinen Kinder,
wir werden sie retten."
"Der Name ist ein kleines Detail,
damit soll man uns
nicht auf die Nerven gehen."
"Wir sorgen dafür,
dass sie ein richtiges Leben haben,
wir geben ihnen auch einen Namen."
Aber wir sind in Sri Lanka geboren,
uns hat nicht der Storch
vor die Haustür
unserer Adoptiveltern gelegt.
Man kann nicht einfach
die Wurzeln abschneiden
und so tun,
als habe es diesen Teil nie gegeben.
* Fernes Hundebellen *
Nach der entmutigenden Erfahrung mit
der Schweizer Botschaft in Colombo
sucht Gaelle ihre leibliche Mutter
auf eigene Faust.
Ich traf meine Mutter zum ersten Mal
in einem Hotel in Sri Lanka.
Das war eine merkwürdige Begegnung,
denn sie
ist für mich eine Unbekannte.
Haben Sie auch hier
einen DNS-Test gemacht?
Den Test machte ich letztes Jahr,
die Resultate bekam ich im Mai.
Nach all den schlechten Erfahrungen
wollte ich einfach ganz sicher sein:
Ist es wirklich meine Mutter?
Der Test ist positiv.
Das Resultat hat viel ausgelöst.
Ich durfte plötzlich
einen Teil Sri Lanka in mir haben.
Ich durfte mich
für meine Herkunft interessieren,
ich durfte wirklich
zwei Mütter haben.
Gaelle kam über die Vermittlung
von Alice Honegger in die Schweiz.
Alice Honegger hat neben
der Vermittlerin Dawn da Silva
den Handel mit sri-lankischen Kindern
ermöglicht.
Die Organisation
mit Sitz in St. Gallen
hat in den Jahren 1980-2000
am meisten Kinder aus Sri Lanka
in die Schweiz gebracht.
Mehr als 250 Adoptionen
sind durch sie zustande gekommen.
In Sri Lanka arbeitete Honegger
mit einem Anwalt zusammen,
der den Babyhandel
in die Wege leitete.
Ich habe sie 1995 kennengelernt.
Meine Eltern
hatten sich das gewünscht,
dass ich sie kennenlerne,
bevor sie stirbt.
Für meine Eltern war sie die Frau,
die ihr Leben verändert hatte.
Der Kanton St. Gallen
gibt eine detaillierte Studie
zu den Vermittlungsaktivitäten
von Alice Honegger in Auftrag,
von den Jahren 1979-1997,
als sie starb.
Es ist haarsträubend -
der Bericht sagt ganz klar,
dass das einzige Interesse
dieser Dame finanzieller Natur war.
Es steht da, es ist eindeutig.
* Sphärische, liegende Klänge *
Sarah Ineichen
trifft in St. Gallen Tamara Kramer,
die ebenfalls
aus Sri Lanka adoptiert wurde.
Sie haben einen Termin
bei der Kantonsregierung.
Und zwar aus gutem Grund:
Beide kamen durch die Vermittlung
von Alice Honegger in die Schweiz.
Tamara und Sarah wollen wissen,
weshalb die Behörden
damals die Augen verschlossen,
obschon die unsauberen Machenschaften
bei den Adoptionen aus Sri Lanka
der Öffentlichkeit bekannt waren.
Die Frage ist, ob der Kanton seine
Verantwortung von damals anerkennt
und den Adoptierten heute hilft.
Grüezi mitenand.
- Grüezi.
Frau Kramer, willkommen.
- Herr Klöti.
Regierungsrat Martin Klöti
ist zuständig für dieses Dossier.
Wir haben inzwischen ...
Mit den gesammelten Dossiers
vieler Adoptierten aus Sri Lanka
in die Schweiz
muss man davon ausgehen,
dass geschätzte 70 % der Papiere
gefälscht sind.
D.h. unsere Suchaktionen,
unsere Suchsysteme
bei den Kantonen und auf Bundesebene
funktionieren bei diesen 30 %,
die stimmen.
Da findet man die Eltern
relativ schnell,
innert einem bis zwei Tagen
und jetzt stellt sich raus ...
Der Bericht von St. Gallen zeigt,
dass Alice Honegger vom Kanton
eine Arbeitserlaubnis erhalten hatte,
obschon sie die rechtlichen
Bedingungen nicht erfüllte.
Und dies Jahr für Jahr,
während 25 Jahren,
mit einem kleinen Unterbruch
von einigen Monaten.
Der Bericht betont:
Dann kann ich als Betroffene
wenigstens
eine Entschuldigung erwarten.
Da haben Sie recht.
Wie Sarah sagt -
ich will auch kein Geld.
Schön wären 25'000 Fr. -
ich kann auch nach Sri Lanka.
Aber ich will kein Geld, sondern
eine Entschuldigung der Behörden.
Steht der Kanton St. Gallen
heute in der Verantwortung?
Natürlich hat der Staat
die Verantwortung. Wer sonst?
Nur: Wir können niemanden mehr
zur Verantwortung ziehen.
Deswegen ist die Art der Anerkennung
der Verantwortung eine andere.
Sie muss genereller sein.
Mit einer Form von Entschuldigung,
dass in jener Zeit Dinge geschahen,
die heute nie mehr geschehen würden.
Die von Alice Honegger
gegründete Stiftung
organisiert
schon lange keine Adoptionen mehr.
Doch sie hat etwa 250 Dossiers
aus jener Zeit archiviert
und weigert sich,
diese an den Kanton auszuhändigen.
Dieses Archiv, das grösste
zu den Adoptionen aus Sri Lanka -
das gehört doch
in professionelle Hände.
Wir haben ein Staatsarchiv,
in dem solche Akten geordnet werden.
Nur: Dazu müsste ich
erst mal zu diesen Akten kommen.
Und wir haben sie nicht erhalten.
Ich bin bei Ihnen:
Wir müssten hier etwas investieren
im Sinne
einer professionellen Archivierung.
Da es sich
um eine private Stiftung handelt,
kann der Kanton aber die Herausgabe
der Dossiers nicht verlangen.
Und der Bund argumentiert, es sei
nicht seine Aufgabe einzugreifen.
Dieses Archiv
wird nicht professionell geführt.
Wer garantiert uns, dass diese
Dossiers nicht einfach verschwinden?
Das kann niemand garantieren.
Wir sind zuständig
für die aktuellen Vermittler.
Sie sprechen
eine private Organisation an,
die damals legal funktionierte
und die dem Gesetz das Kantons
unterliegt.
Wir wissen,
dass der Kanton St. Gallen
mit dieser Stiftung diesbezüglich
in Kontakt ist, aber mehr nicht.
Kurzum: Bund und Kanton schieben sich
gegenseitig den Schwarzen Peter zu.
Doch die Zeit drängt.
Sarah Ineichen hat ihr Dossier
von der Stiftung Honegger verlangt.
Erhalten hat sie die Dokumente
einer anderen Adoptierten,
was zeigt, wie fehlerhaft
dieses Archiv geführt wird.
Sarah will dem heutigen
Verantwortlichen der Stiftung
einen Besuch abstatten und ihm
die falschen Dokumente zurückbringen.
Wir begleiten sie.
Grüezi.
- Grüezi wohl.
Sie können vielleicht
dieses Dossier ...
Sie haben
das falsche Dossier geschickt.
Ich habe Ihnen den Namen meiner
leiblichen Mutter angegeben ...
Die Daten habe ich doch nicht.
- ... mein Geburtsdatum.
Sie schickten mir das Dossier
einer Adoption zehn Jahre später.
Ja, weil ... Ich habe Ihnen ...
Ich würde gern mit Ihnen
das Gespräch suchen
und Sie bitten, ob Sie alle Dossiers
ins Staatsarchiv übergeben könnten.
Das darf ich gar nicht.
Ich war beim Kanton.
Ich sagte schon mal:
In diesen Dossiers sind nur
Informationen zu den Adoptiveltern.
Das ...
- Punkt.
Die Dame des Kantons sagte,
da gebe es Persönlichkeitsschutz.
D.h. ich müsste
die Adoptiveltern fragen,
ob ich die Dossiers rausgeben kann.
Und wenn alle Adoptiveltern
das Okay geben,
wären Sie bereit,
die Unterlagen ins Archiv zu geben?
Nein, ins Archiv nicht.
Das sowieso nicht.
Wenn schon den direkt Betroffenen.
Das Archiv ist kein Thema.
Ich habe gemerkt, wie das rauskommt.
Es geht darum, dass die Adoptierten
ihre Dossiers möchten,
um eine irgendeine Chance zu haben,
ihre Mütter zu finden.
Denn die Mütter suchen die Kinder.
Nicht zu wissen,
wie man heisst, woher man kommt
und ob unsere Eltern uns
überhaupt freiwillig gaben ...
Ich habe Mütter getroffen,
denen man bei der Geburt sagte,
das Baby sei gestorben,
und dann gab man es weg.
Es wurde dann über Thavanesan,
über Alice Honegger
in die Schweiz adoptiert.
Und das ist nicht richtig.
- Was soll ich jetzt da machen?
Ich gebe die Dossiers nicht raus,
das könnt ihr vergessen.
In gewissen Dossiers
sind z.B. Listen
von Baby-Bestellungen aufgetaucht,
erstellt von Ihrer Mutter:
"Familie XY hätte gern ein süsses
Mädchen, bitte nicht zu dunkel."
"Wir hätten gern ein liebes Kind
und eins mit dunkeln Haaren."
Dunkle Haare sind aber
in Sri Lanka ziemlich üblich,
wenn ich das richtig einschätze.
Ja, aber dass man bestellt ...
- Hören Sie doch auf mit so Quatsch.
Ich habe mich unwohl gefühlt.
Schon an diesem Ort zu sein.
Ihm gegenüber als adoptierte Person.
Vor ihm zu stehen.
Und andererseits trotzdem
unsere Rechte einzufordern.
Denn es gibt viele Adoptierte,
die Schwierigkeiten haben,
für ihre Rechte einzustehen,
weil es ihnen heute psychologisch
einfach nicht gut geht.
Sarah
ist auf dem Weg zu Pedro Sutter.
Er ist Sozialarbeiter und arbeitete
früher im Bereich Adoptionen.
Hallo, Sarah.
- Hallo, Pedro. Wie geht's?
Pedro Sutter hätte 1984 die Nachfolge
von Alice Honegger antreten sollen.
Doch bevor er
die Leitung der Stiftung übernimmt,
will er sich in Sri Lanka
ein eigenes Bild
der lokalen Bedingungen
der Adoptionen machen.
Was er da entdeckt,
schockiert ihn zutiefst.
In der Folge kündigt Pedro Sutter.
Du schreibst auch detailliert
über die Situationen,
wie es auf den Baby-Farmen aussieht.
Wie war es dort für dich?
Diese Art von Adoption
kann ich nicht unterstützen.
Das war ein ganz einfacher Raum,
in dem sechs Frauen
auf Matratzen lagen,
mit ihren neugeborenen Babys.
Dort waren sie
wohl zwei, drei Wochen,
bis die Übergabe vor Gericht
erfolgte.
Pedro Sutter schreibt damals
einen vernichtenden Bericht.
Heute noch
erinnert sich Pedro Sutter,
dass Alice Honegger
ihm damals in Sri Lanka
etwas Merkwürdiges anvertraut hatte.
Sie kam am 31. August 1984
in Colombo an.
Noch am selben Tag
traf ich sie dort.
Bei Frau Thavanesan.
Sie sagte mir dann,
sie sei kürzlich mit Dr. Oehler
auf dem Bundesamt gewesen
und habe
mit dem obersten Chef gesprochen.
Und ...
Es werde nun ein schweizerisch
einheitliches Verfahren erlassen.
D.h. in Zukunft sei die
Personaliendurchgabe der Kinder
wieder mit Telex erlaubt.
Das war irgendein Problem, dass das
per Telex nicht mehr möglich war.
Das war dann komplizierter
für die Adoptiveltern.
Sie und Herr Oehler haben
den Weg dann wieder frei gemacht.
Das Ziel
war eine Erleichterung der Prozedur?
Ja, nach dieser Aussage ganz klar.
Edgar Oehler, der mit Alice Honegger
beim Bundesamt für Ausländerfragen
vorstellig wird,
ist kein Unbekannter.
Edgar Oehler
gilt als König von St. Gallen.
Gefürchtet und respektiert.
CVP-Nationalrat
zwischen 1971 und 1995.
Enger Freund
von Bundesrat Kurt Furgler,
damaliger Chef
des Justiz- und Polizeidepartements.
Grösster Arbeitgeber
im Kanton St. Gallen.
Mächtiger Lobbyist
für die Zigarettenindustrie.
Gemäss der Zeitschrift "BILANZ"
beläuft sich sein Vermögen
auf 175 Mio. Fr.
Zwischen 1980 und 1984
adoptiert Edgar Oehler
vier Mädchen aus Sri Lanka -
durch die Vermittlungsagentur
von Alice Honegger.
Er ist also direkt betroffen.
Deshalb stellt sich die Frage: Was
haben Edgar Oehler und Alice Honegger
vom Bundesamt für Ausländerfragen
in Bezug auf Sri Lanka verlangt?
Ich wollte einfach wissen, was
positiv, falsch oder unehrlich ist.
Deshalb ging ich dahin.
Gemäss Pedro Sutter wollte er
den Adoptionsprozess beschleunigen.
Das ist jetzt eine Detailfrage ...
Da erinnere ich mich nicht mehr.
Das war vor 18 Jahren.
Seither ging vieles
durch meine Ohren.
Nicht in dieser Sache,
aber vom Leben, Geschäft ...
Hat Frau Honegger
von ihrem Schutz profitiert?
Von meiner ...
Schutz?
- Ja.
Ich habe sie sehr wenig getroffen.
Ich würde sagen ... drei-, viermal.
Aber das hätte sie ...
Ich hätte nicht gemerkt,
dass ich sie unterstütze.
Der Kanton wagte es nicht, etwas
gegen Frau Honegger zu unternehmen,
weil Sie sie schützten.
Non, rien du tout.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Ich bin ein Politiker, der auch
immer wieder angeschossen wurde.
Viele Medien berichteten
über den Kinderhandel in Sri Lanka.
Erinnern Sie sich daran?
Non.
Gar keine Erinnerung?
Davon habe ich nie
etwas gehört und gelesen.
Sie waren Journalist, Chefredaktor,
Sie sassen in Kommissionen,
in denen es um Aussenpolitik ging.
Diese Frage
betrifft Sie auch persönlich -
wie ist es möglich,
dass Sie davon noch nie gehört haben?
Es ist offenbar alles
an mir vorbeigegangen.
Also ... Hätte ich etwas gemerkt,
wäre ich massiv drauflosgegangen.
Mehr als den Hinweis auf Detailfragen
und verlorene Erinnerungen
ist nicht zu erfahren.
Sarah trifft sich mit Dida Guigan,
die sich ebenfalls für
die Rechte von Adoptierten einsetzt.
Salut.
- Salut, ca va?
Dida ist Präsidentin
von Born in Lebanon,
der Vereinigung
für Adoptierte aus dem Libanon.
Sarah präsidiert Back To The Roots,
die Organisation
für Adoptierte aus Sri Lanka.
Schön, dass wir die Arbeit
zwischen unseren Vereinigungen
etwas vorantreiben können.
Ja, mal schauen,
welche Anliegen wir gemeinsam haben,
z.B. auf Bundesebene.
Worauf legt ihr momentan den Fokus?
Seit einem Jahr haben 172 Adoptierte
aus Sri Lanka in der Schweiz
mit uns Kontakt aufgenommen.
Etwa jeden dritten Tag
kommt eine neue Person dazu.
Bei uns haben viele
schon an andere Türen angeklopft,
aber am Schluss landen alle bei uns.
Wir tun, was wir können, aber es
übersteigt langsam unsere Kapazität.
Sri Lanka
ist wohl nur die Spitze des Eisbergs
in der Geschichte
der internationalen Adoptionen.
In den Jahren zwischen 1980 und 2000
wurden 13'400 ausländische Kinder
in die Schweiz adoptiert:
Internationale Adoptionen boomen.
In der Schweiz
und in anderen westlichen Ländern
sind sie die Lösung
für ungewollt kinderlose Paare.
In Ländern wie Korea,
Indien, Brasilien, Chile, Guatemala,
meist durch bewaffnete Konflikte
destabilisiert,
sind die Adoptionspraktiken
genauso fragwürdig wie in Sri Lanka.
Wir wollen das Beispiel Libanon
genauer anschauen.
In den 1980er-Jahren wütet im Libanon
ein brutaler Bürgerkrieg.
Das Land versinkt im Chaos.
Internationale Adoptionen
haben Hochsaison.
* Kinderlärm *
Dida Guigan
kommt 1984 in Beirut zur Welt.
Wir treffen sie am Hafen von Jounieh,
im Norden von Beirut.
Ich bin nie mehr
hierher zurückgekehrt.
Genau von hier habe ich damals
den libanesischen Boden verlassen.
Mein erster Transport fand in einem
dieser kleinen Fischerboote statt,
das mich und meine Adoptiveltern
zur Fähre auf Zypern brachte,
von wo aus
die Reise dann weiterging.
Es gab wenige Menschen,
die das Risiko auf sich nahmen,
hierherzukommen,
z.B. meine Adoptiveltern,
die keine Angst hatten.
Wie alt waren Sie damals?
Ich war knapp ... acht Tage alt.
Acht Tage und die Sache ist erledigt.
Denn das im Libanon angewendete
System ist noch etwas perfider
als jenes in Sri Lanka:
Dank einer falschen Geburtsurkunde
eines Arztes
wurde Dida als biologische Tochter
ihrer Adoptiveltern erfasst.
Offiziell
wurde sie also nie adoptiert.
Eine radikale Methode, die damals in
mehreren Ländern praktiziert wurde,
um die Kontrollen der Behörden
zu umgehen.
Zurück in der Schweiz
haben die Adoptiveltern
Dida noch formell adoptiert.
Doch längst nicht alle Adoptiveltern
haben das getan.
Im Libanon profitieren damals
auf dem Adoptionsmarkt
alle Arten von Vermittlern
von den Kriegswirren:
Anwälte, Ärzte, Schwestern, Hebammen.
* Leises Wimmern *
Über verschiedene
unterschiedliche Quellen
stossen wir auf eine Tonaufnahme,
die ohne das Wissen der Vermittlerin
vor einigen Jahren
aufgezeichnet wurde.
Die Person beschreibt,
wie es damals vor sich ging.
Alle Ärzte sind Gynäkologen.
Sie wissen alle,
dass ich die Adoptionen mache,
sie haben Vertrauen in mich,
auch wenn es um die Ausgaben geht,
Geld, das man dem Krankenhaus
zahlen muss oder dem Arzt.
Einmal fragte ich einen Arzt:
"Wie viel wollen Sie?"
Er sagte: "240'000 $."
Sie wollen einfach das Geld,
nehmen nicht einmal einen Scheck.
Man muss das Waisenhaus bezahlen,
die Dokumente und mein Honorar.
Ich kassiere das Geld ein,
5'000 $ pro Adoption.
Davon bekomme ich dann
nicht einmal 1'500 $.
In Bern im Bundesarchiv
finden wir die Bestätigung
für diese Vorgehensweisen.
Thierry Hartmann,
Recherchejournalist bei RTS,
durfte
den diplomatischen Briefverkehr
der Schweizer Botschaft im Libanon
anschauen, jedoch ohne zu filmen.
Gemäss den Unterlagen macht
das Bundesamt für Ausländerfragen
die Schweizer Botschaft im Libanon
auf eine verdächtige Vermittlung
aufmerksam.
Diese wird von einer Anwältin
in Beirut betrieben,
die horrende Vermittlungsgebühren
verlangt.
Am 6. August 1987 schreibt
das Bundesamt für Ausländerfragen:
Im Archiv finden wir ein Schreiben
des Rechtsberaters
der Schweizer Botschaft,
das auf ein Auskunftsersuchen
über die rechtlichen Voraussetzungen
für eine Adoption im Libanon
antwortet.
Im Schreiben werden verschiedene
Vorgehensweisen beschrieben.
Am 5. Januar 1988 wird vor
den Gepflogenheiten im Land gewarnt.
In den 1980er-Jahren
spielen im Libanon die christlichen
Geistlichen eine zentrale Rolle.
Die religiösen Gerichte
genehmigten Adoptionen
und die christlichen Kinderheime
konnten, wenn nötig,
sogar Geburtsurkunden ausstellen.
Zwei Namen tauchen immer wieder auf:
das Kinderheim St. Vincent de Paul
und das Waisenhaus Bon Pasteur.
* Hupen *
Wir haben einen Termin
in der Altstadt von Sidon,
beim griechisch-katholischen
Erzbischof.
Der amtierende Erzbischof
war damals noch nicht im Amt,
Es gab in diesen Waisenhäusern
Menschen,
die immer wieder Kinder wegbrachten.
Das war nicht böswillig,
sie wollten das nicht tun.
Aber der Krieg zwingt einen,
so zu handeln.
Aber der Krieg
entschuldigt nicht alles.
Die Vermittler, die aus der Adoption
ein Geschäft machten,
hatten gute Adressen.
Das bestätigt eine Notiz
der Schweizer Botschaft in Beirut
vom 22. Dezember 1980.
Darin sind die Empfehlungen
der verantwortlichen Schwester
des Waisenhauses St. Vincent de Paul
festgehalten.
Sie erklärt, dass das Waisenhaus
das Prozedere abkürzen kann,
um die Dinge zu beschleunigen.
Anders gesagt: St. Vincent de Paul
und Le Bon Pasteur
haben bei diesem Handel zumindest
eine unterstützende Rolle gespielt.
Der protestantische Pfarrer
Habib Badr
hat das konfessionelle Gericht
präsidiert,
das während des Bürgerkrieges
über die Adoptionen befand.
Wussten Sie, woher diese Babys kamen?
Nein,
das war die grosse Frage für uns,
für mich ganz besonders.
Und es ist auch einer der Gründe,
weshalb wir die Adoptionen
nach einiger Zeit
nicht mehr durchgeführt haben,
weil es nicht möglich war
zu erfahren,
wer die leibliche Mutter ist.
Das wurde für mich als Präsident
des Gerichts ein Dilemma:
"Soll ich diese Frage stellen?"
- Welche Frage?
Die Frage, wer die Mutter ist,
wer die Eltern sind,
wieso sie das Kind
weggegeben haben usw.
Bevor ich
für eine Adoption entscheide -
soll ich diese Frage stellen
oder nicht?
Denn vielleicht
stellt sie ja das Kind eines Tages,
aber vielleicht auch nicht.
Und wie haben Sie für sich
diese Frage beantwortet?
Ich habe entschieden,
es nicht wissen zu wollen.
Ich habe beschlossen,
dass es eine Entscheidung zwischen
zwei schlechten Varianten ist.
Es ist schlecht, es zu wissen
und schlecht, es nicht zu wissen.
Damals dachte ich, es sei
weniger schlecht es nicht zu wissen.
* Klagende östliche Klänge *
Für Dida aber
war es unabdingbar, es zu wissen.
Ich war wie besessen davon,
herauszufinden,
wer meine leibliche Mutter ist.
Ohne Antworten
ist man zu allem bereit.
Ich war bereit, im Libanon zu leben,
ich war bereit, zu sterben.
Mein einziges Ziel im Leben war,
meine leiblichen Eltern zu finden.
Aber eigentlich suchte ich nicht
meine Eltern, sondern die Wahrheit,
damit ich
in meinem Leben weiterkomme.
Und genau das ist das Problem.
Betrachtet man die
Adoptionsbedingungen aus jener Zeit,
mit falschen Geburtsurkunden,
ohne Namen der leiblichen Mutter,
wird die Suche nach der Wahrheit
praktisch unmöglich.
Es wird zehn Jahre dauern, bis Dida
ihre leibliche Mutter findet.
Sie zieht für einige Jahre
nach Beirut,
sie lernt Arabisch und schafft es,
den Namen ihrer Mutter und ihre
damalige Adresse ausfindig zu machen.
Hier sind wir vor der dem Haus,
in dem meine leibliche Mutter
damals wohnte.
Ich habe dieses Haus
sehr lange gesucht.
Ich war nicht sicher,
ob es wirklich hier ist.
Doch dann
traf ich die Hausbesitzerin,
sie sass dort auf der Bank,
schaute mich ganz intensiv an
und murmelte auf Arabisch:
"Ich weiss, wer du bist."
Da habe ich begriffen,
dass ich am richtigen Ort bin,
denn ich gleiche
meiner leiblichen Mutter sehr.
2012 wird sie von einem libanesischen
Fernsehteam kontaktiert.
Sie wollen eine Reportage über Didas
Suche machen und bieten ihr Hilfe an.
Sie schaffen es,
die Mutter aufzuspüren
und entdecken etwas Unglaubliches:
eine Zugstunde vom Dorf entfernt,
in dem Dida aufgewachsen ist.
In Beirut
traut Dida ihren Ohren nicht.
Allo?
Allo, bonjour.
- Bonjour.
Darf ich dich fragen,
wieso du deine Mama suchst?
Ich möchte sie kennenlernen,
ich möchte wissen, wie sie aussieht,
ich möchte wissen,
wie ihr Leben verlaufen ist.
In meinem Leben ist viel passiert.
Ich habe mich so nach dir gesehnt,
aber gleichzeitig hatte ich
solche Angst, ich habe nur geweint.
Ich war sehr krank, ich ging
von einem Psychiater zum nächsten,
ich wollte meinem Leben
ein Ende setzen.
Es ist zu schwer,
am Telefon darüber zu reden.
Kein Problem.
Um ganz sicher zu sein,
macht Dida einen DNS-Test.
Er ist positiv - also macht sie sich,
zusammen mit dem libanesischen Fern-
sehen, auf den Weg in die Schweiz.
Salut.
* Melancholischer Gesang *
Salut. Ca va?
Geht's dir gut?
- Ja, und dir?
Ich muss dich
die ganze Zeit anschauen.
Ich habe dich weggegeben,
aber nie ganz.
Ich habe immer gehofft,
dich eines Tages wiederzusehen.
Wenn man seine Wurzeln sucht,
dann bedeutet das nicht nur, den
Namen der Familie herauszufinden.
Es bedeutet auch,
eine Geschichte zu hören -
eine schöne oder eine schmerzhafte.
Und meistens
ist es eine schmerzhafte.
Ich bin gespalten, einerseits
muss ich gewisse Dinge respektieren,
die einfach zu schmerzhaft sind,
und andererseits
ist da auch mein Bedürfnis,
Licht ins Dunkel zu bringen, damit
ich überhaupt weitermachen kann.
Die Geschichte von Dida,
die im Libanon begonnen hat,
ist aussergewöhnlich.
Aber sie ist nicht allein
mit ihrem Schicksal.
Tausenden von Adoptierten wie Dida
wurde immer wieder erklärt,
dass sie durch die Adoption
vor einem schlimmeren Leben
bewahrt worden seien.
Für mich machen solche Aussagen
überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Sie sprechen von Rettung.
Aber die Wahrheit ist,
dass da eine Mutter war,
die in Kriegszeiten schwanger wurde
von einem Mann,
mit dem sie nicht verheiratet war
und der ihr Gewalt angetan hatte.
Diese Frau musste ihr Baby
ganz alleine zur Welt bringen,
in einem Land, in dem die Frauen-
rechte nicht respektiert werden
und in dem sie das Kind
nicht offiziell anmelden konnte.
Man sagte ihr, es sei besser,
sich vom Kind zu trennen.
Das ist die Grundlage,
auf denen internationale Adoptionen
möglich gemacht wurden.
Es ging also ganz klar nicht darum,
einer Frau in einer schwierigen
Situation zu helfen,
und auch nicht einem Kind,
das vielleicht seine Eltern
im Krieg verloren hätte -
und auch nicht, einer armen Frau zu
helfen, meine Mutter war nicht arm.
Diese Aussagen über Rettung
dienen nur als Vorwand,
um die Nachfrage
nach Adoptionskindern
aus der westlichen Welt
zu verdecken.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
* Melancholischer arabischer Gesang *
Als Dida ihre Mutter wiederfand,
hat sie etwas Grundlegendes erfahren.
Ich habe begriffen,
dass meine Mutter in einer psychisch
enorm verletzlichen Situation war,
als sie alleine den Entscheid traf,
sich von mir zu trennen.
Es ging nicht darum, dass sie
als Mutter ihr Kind nicht wollte.
* Melancholischer arabischer Gesang *
Diese Erkenntnis hat etwa 70 %
meiner Wunden geheilt.
Die Wunden heilen oder sie
zumindest erträglicher machen.